I know Hario he's a great person he
couldn't vote for me at the time now he
can vote for me once he gets out I love
Snoop de double Che what's your favorite
Death Row Record Trump all of them all
of the Death Row Records don't try to
pin me down I see what he just excuse me
excuse me fake news fake
[Laughter]
news for they tried to give me the
virus I beat the virus say they try to
they they tried to give the vir like who
is that
I beat the like yeah he beat it man Jam
Lea Fox is just a great performer he
gets he gets the voice he's not doing
too much of the physicality there at all
but so it's just a vocal impression but
it's almost perfect